honey in your catrice
how's it going star warriors
that's true
how's it going star warriors we're gonna
watch today
episode five of visions thanks john one
way to come up with a good catchphrase
is you should intentionally set out for
a catcher so they always go right right
yeah i don't just come naturally you
gotta think no you gotta work really
hard and let everyone know you worked
really hard
i've really been enjoying this show guys
hit that like button if you end up
enjoying our reaction or the dislike
doesn't matter engagements engagement
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next star
wars reaction is up full length watch
along so we stick it with the time code
or over at our patreon page same tier we
have reaction highlights and watch
alongs included for many shows lastly
thank you to prothom or jaden honestly i
don't know which one edited this but
your names were mentioned that's what
counts you did a good job good employers
that you got here
the ninth jedi
number nine many generations have passed
since the light of the jedi protected
the galaxy but margrave journal ruler of
the planet hides islam as a plan
his lawn
using these crystals he seeks to restore
the jedi by reforging their ancient
weapons
lightsabers nice
they had their own sinister plan to hunt
all suspected jedi and bring forth a new
era of sith rule
that was clever look like there's a face
in there yeah
is that a kyber asteroid huh join me in
the fight to unite our war-torn galaxy
and restore peace
i will be waiting it's a trap
the real issue is whether this juror can
be trusted or not
[Music]
he has red eyes and he looks pretty evil
yeah
if this is some kind of trap to kill
jedi did everyone show up here believing
that they could survive it
or did you decide it was worth the risk
just to obtain a lightsaber let's have a
philosophy debate instead
let's not even go to the planet with the
kyber crystal you said that it was
strong here
i sense the dark side in this place
i doubt
i see the seven jedi have already
gathered
so i am sure he will arrive soon
all right then
i am an oil man
eat your crystals
i eat them up
[Music]
honey have you seen my creepy mask
and my cloak my sinister cloak
whoa
so you can change the length on this one
oh neat huh
actually i've tempered the kyber
crystals on each lightsaber so it
reflects the user's connection with my
horse
the color and the length will vary
depending on the jedi using it
he's really connected look how long that
lightsaber is
barely fits in the room i'm so connected
[Laughter]
remember that while the force exists in
every living thing only those
individuals who develop their connection
to it will have the power to wield it
yeah
i wonder what color this lightsaber will
turn when it's finally in the hands of a
real jedi
god i love this series yeah
this is pretty great man do one every
year
jedi ships unlikely since they were
summoned to the aerial temple
oh boy
cara
i need you to take these to the temple
immediately i'll be too busy looking
after our newly arrived visitors
you're all strange
this is the last time we'll see each
other oh my god
be careful and may the force be with you
you really sound like you're gonna die
dad
you have illicitly manufactured several
lightsabers for masterless jedi where
exactly did you get that from
from the one who enlisted your services
to make them
la jima you will hand over the illegal
lightsabers and come with us oh yeah
refusal is not
bounce off his hand yeah like ricocheted
[Music]
[Music]
sick looking logo
[Music]
a lightsaber a real lightsaber
touch it the remaining sabers should be
arriving very shortly i don't know
there's something still incredibly
ominous about this room
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ] she go for oh yeah
awesome awesome continue your training
oh wow she's a good driver yes
she and that droid are an effective team
damn we're gonna go
[Music]
did lightsaber change colors or is that
just it looks like it's starting to get
stronger green yeah yeah
[Music]
there goes the best damn kid in the
galaxy
i need for you to take us to the aerial
temple immediately
[Laughter]
no matter where you are in the galaxy
take this and get me to the temple
i might as well
[Laughter]
oh my god
it's like having a sloth
[Laughter]
even this robot is pacing
something's coming do you think it's the
margrave ship
whoa
thank you
don't mention it
i'm the daughter of the saber-smith
lajima
not kara dune but my father was caught
and taken away by the jedi hunters
please use these to help me save him
[Laughter]
something doesn't feel right
i don't think we have a choice we'll
have to wait for the margrave to arrive
sinister to the core
that was awesome
[ __ ]
oh no
[Applause]
i have been here the entire time
we are acolytes of the sith and sworn to
the dark side and we are here to put an
end to your pitiful plans of restoring
the jedi order wow
holy [ __ ] this is awesome
we're gonna play on expectations
our hunters have taken your father to a
distant star system where you'll never
see him again and any attempt to rescue
him will result in failure
oh
i knew it he looked too shocked
[Music]
dude i love the animation of her
specific lightsaber yeah
nice moves
[Music]
rodents
[Music]
oh my god let's go camera movement i
dreamt up for this
that
[Laughter]
yes
we'll suffer churros
oh
[Music]
she's the ninth jedi
grab the lightsaber
force it
this isn't you
i apologize i became consumed by the
others darkness
like color psychology i know
the number of jedi who answered my call
were killed and sith were sent in their
place
so i hid myself in their presence in
order to determine who was sith they
learned about your father and i could
not be there to help will you help me
save him
of course i will hmm
help us restore peace to the galaxy and
take your place as the ninth jedi so we
can re-establish the jedi order
[Music]
oh man
that light
[Applause]
what about our pups
they gotta go they gotta go rescue them
ah it's like a lightsaber
it's like a lightsaber
but it's so long
looks like from the original star wars
poster
he's holding it yeah
all right that's my favorite one that
was an awesome
one yeah that was great i was really
emotionally hooked into that too yeah
that was great
it was like
david lynch's star wars
it actually felt like the beginning of
the 1970s superman movie okay they're
talking to
uh zod yeah and then they're sentencing
him yeah yeah
like in the beginning to me that's
that's my first one
[Music]
yeah this was great because it was the
first one out of the five that truly
emotionally hooked me like i was very
i've been in awe of it for a variety of
reasons per episode
but this one i really cared about the
main character cara
uh i really cared about the conflict she
was in i was heavily invested in the
mystery of like
this guy's bad right i got a guy's gotta
be bad i lured the jet out here you know
yeah and i didn't see that twist coming
that was a really great reveal
and uh yeah i was just so pulled into
that like the animation was cool the
action was awesome i love the speeder
bike uh chase that like feels like a nod
to return of the jedi but in a different
landscape and i love how they like toyed
with the action scene too where she's
able to drive it and do some crazy
lightsaber action at the same time
i love the color psychology elements to
it like really
letting the
because i i'm not like
an expert on color psychology there was
like one day in my life where i got like
fascinated with like ooh what does this
color mean what does this color mean you
know like green medium symbolizing
rebirth it makes sense why her
lightsaber would turn to green most of
the time yeah
blue there's i mean everyone has like
there's a lot of different definitions
for what colors mean that's why i
realize you can't just narrow it down to
one it's like red can mean passion but
it could also mean dangers you know like
having the sith be red well there's a
canonical breakdown it's like what every
lightsaber color specifically alludes to
and whatever but but they made yeah like
really wonderful use i thought of it
across this episode yeah and i didn't uh
i wasn't aware of that thing that you
just said
but
but i'm sure that it also plays into you
know the what like colors generally i
mean yeah i mean it's it's a lot of it's
based on
probably the the original color
psychology that shows up across all
sorts of media but that's something that
hasn't really been explored in the films
yeah like really establishing why these
colors why one is blue and all that
um
so i i loved having that angle to it but
yeah i was just really invested in it
and i thought the action was great like
the lightsaber duels at the end was
awesome you know i love that
i don't know how to describe that anime
shake motion with fights i guess it's
like this slight track like imagine my
hands the camera it's like this light
little tracking that's following every
movement little by little it's handheld
you know yeah it's like they're moving
the camera in unison with certain
movements on screen yeah
and it's not hyper done but it makes it
feel more uh like there's an actual
camera here instead of it being animated
you know absolutely and i've it's always
been like the dc animated films and even
the mortal kombat animated movies uh
they've they've actually adapted that
into their style a little bit as well
and so i love seeing it here on display
too uh which was just so cool to behold
like this this to me was the perfect
marriage of everything i've wanted this
show to actually turn out to be
like uh i love the first episode a lot
um for for very different reasons this
to me felt like real star wars yeah this
felt like true star wars and i love
where it takes place because it sounds
like it takes place
like centuries after everything like
this is way in the future
um
where like
things have been practically extinct so
this is not definitely messing with
canonically the timeline of what we know
what's going to happen it's a very
different it's it's so far in the future
and they're trying to do the the rebirth
of the jedi and of course at least the
rebirth of sith too yeah but
just that reveal was awesome like saying
like here's what the colors mean you
know and and they they they feel so uh
what's the word i'm looking for not
affable uh
they seem they they they do seem like
students are innocent the the the sith's
hanging out everyone shows up yeah yeah
they all feel seem like a little aloof
about the whole thing yeah everybody
feels like they're in the same relatable
position of like
not too open because i don't know who
any of you guys are and this could be a
trap but also i mean we're all here for
the same reason right yeah you know
we're all trying to figure out this
mystery and hey none of us are
malevolent right yeah i just love how
they play into the mislead of it all
like you really think
that this robot's definitely freaking
evil you know that's an evil robot
oh you know that guy he's alerting there
he's evil you know it yeah one is it
seems like the dad was gonna be him yeah
i thought that's what i thought too and
i thought like it was at first i was
like what a contrast because he seems
like such a calm guy he's a sweet guy
but yeah i loved too in in combination
with the colors how they made like early
on in the episode i was thinking like
they really make it a moment or like a
miniature event when they actually light
up the saber you know and so to
establish that already where it's like
the first time you see one light up in
the shop and you're like oh you know you
be you kind of behold the prowess and
the power you know leading up to that
moment where they all ignite them and
they all turn out red like yeah it made
for such a wonderfully tense moment
backed by a great little character story
happening on the ground with cara and
her dad and again it's another one of
those classic moments of like hey i'm
trying to help out the resistance uh
we're in deep [ __ ] right now you go take
these and you go yeah i'm gonna tell you
but i'm about to go be brave right now
so you know you're gonna have to carry
on the legacy with both of us and then
you know having to go find him later but
you know even the way that they
distributed the amount of like not
everybody who showed up to the temple is
a sith you had that one guy ethan who's
like that's a great way to introduce the
scenario too where it's like suddenly we
arrive here with him and he is one of
the few who is like immediately
not a sith or good and i like that you
even had the other guy who who had the
purple lightsaber and it seemed to like
change color almost uh if i was tracking
that right visually and he's like you
know i got so overwhelmed like i liked
they included
those because it fleshed it out that
much further and it added
like a nuance and it added to the
tension of like okay it's not so much
that like all of them are evil and this
is a massacre but also they're super
outgunned and now they're about to form
this little ragtag crew that's gonna
carry on this next leg of the adventure
i love how the main guy who goes up to
me is like come on man it's not you
hey you're right i know
starks are man
so menacing and cool i just i didn't
want to just got caught in the moment
yeah you know everyone was doing it red
really pops and everyone had it
maybe i was like i was angry because i
couldn't have one too
[Laughter]
all of a sudden i got one
my first lightsaber man
just turn red i got the call what do you
want i was gonna take any lightsaber i
got okay
no matter what it says about me
but yeah like this well the conflict of
that is so cool because
it
it's an interesting it's an awesome
world building technique to use for the
lightsabers like i don't i don't
seen clone wars seeing a lot of rebels
like
a lot of essential episodes of rebels
and uh i i haven't of course we've seen
the bad batch together but
there's nothing in the
movies that i can recall that really
have something of this it seems like
this is the the the the uh
the
what's it called jedi smith
so what are you calling oh oh oh um i
mean yeah like it's like the lightsaber
smith or a black smith yeah like
hypersmith
you think that's what it's called i
remember the actual terminology it was
from but yeah having him in there and
what he developed
with the
with the lightsaber how it though the
length of how it extends is a symbolic
connection with how the user is with the
force and also the color too
it does create um a different atmosphere
for when the lightsabers are around and
it it makes it feel character based and
it gives more weight to
the lightsabers they're beyond just like
cool jedi weapons there's something
emotional associated with it now beyond
just us what we know about how [ __ ]
important a lightsaber is it's just it's
the most important thing
but just seeing like how it really tells
you who they are as a person yeah was it
was such a great detail to make it feel
more character based and um i just make
the jedi's feel richer the the
lightsabers feel more rich oh totally
because it it matches it it matches with
the mysticism of the jedi order in
general and it makes this
iconic motif of star wars feel like a
living thing that interacts with its
owner that much more yeah and for the
visual media because from what i from
like you know hearing people talk over
the years i get the sense that's way
more explored in the books and stuff
like that yeah yeah and so it was cool
to see like yeah this this was like a
really to me well proportioned episode
where i i loved the hook like okay we've
got this transmission we're meeting up
in this weird temple and you cut to down
on the ground and what that's like and
you have these two very different auras
because like when you're on the ground
you've got like you know she's riding
the bike or the speeder past the giant
uh like catapult things they use to pull
down the kyber asteroids like you know
just like the amount of scope and
tangibility that went into that plus
then the plot twists and you know the
character beats and stuff like that and
while you know it's more expository in
some of the dialogue than other episodes
like i thought this was really
well proportioned for the most part you
know yeah i felt like real animates me
too i think what you can do is like a
combination of episode three and five
and that could be a movie
yeah that makes sense because they they
both center heavily around the the saber
specifically the kyber and the kyber
crystal yeah and uh yeah you you do that
and then also you just make sure they're
set on the same timeline yeah and it
worked and you got like your villains
set up already
you could be influenced by the sith and
then i love the story of them trying to
give rise to the jedi order again
this is cool it would be cool movie
would be a cool new trilogy honestly it
would be a cool anime movie if you just
did this one movie yeah and their
animation the animation styles from
those two are not too far off from one
another yeah and i love i loved the look
of the animation here and just the
quality of like they had so much
personality in the light and the
depiction of each part of the world and
two i don't know just that dynamic of
like having her be the one to have to
deliver these like priceless artifacts
that are also the keys to reigniting the
resistance and you know the good of the
galaxy i even like the droid who was
like a lazy worker yeah a guy who just
good moves kids works enough to not get
fired yeah
just drinks his oil tea all day they
love how they did it as if he's smoking
yeah but you can't do them smoking you
just pack a bowl of
a tea of
oolong very
j.r.r token yeah
jk token j k simmons all right guys well
what'd you think about this episode did
you like it as much as us leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and last but
not least let's do a page
jason as we're recording this
a few days ago you messaged me saying
you're gonna be in california i replied
let's kick it
you didn't reply anything to me oh
instead you sent me photos of cazzy
reacts cosplaying
cool
does that mean we're gonna kick it are
we just tell me you're in la and you're
not gonna hang out with me you're gonna
watch some cazzy videos and pretend like
you kicked it what the hell man there's
a whole home here you can come too
chill
drink some tea that looks like you're
smoking
oh yeah
jason would love that we could watch
i don't want to get demonetized so i got
to change the word or something to
rhymes with it
we could watch
ten high together
oh yeah
good
oh yeah yeah yeah i got you japanese
porn uh-huh japanese pornography
the drawn format john now we're demonic
and it's all about we're going up jason
you got to stop watching that stuff man
word yeah because we alluded to
something that exists in real life jason
dolan you and i should go bowling that
would be great buddy dude you're never
boring and never trolling only once were
we on the phone and i started snoring
good thing i put you on mute because
you're too cute to let you know the
truth
we're done we're done
[Music]
you